nights go the golden knights have a
chance to knock out the colorado
avalanche with a win tonight
we do have live team coverage of course
john treats chatting with fans outside
but first we're going to head out to
sports director chris matthews
with a preview hey chris
hey kirsten how you doing today i'll
tell you what they got the music playing
that means we're getting closer and
closer
to puck drop here it's a six o'clock
start here in las vegas of course game
six
avalanche and the knights they can close
it out the team with a 3-2 series lead
has a 79 chance of winning this so vegas
two games to win one they can do it
tonight you can see right here they got
all the
the towels the rally towels they're all
set to go there will be
over 18 000 once again inside this as
they get the ice ready for tonight's big
game six vegas golden knights and the
colorado avalanche might mention
vegas in that three-game winning streak
each of those three games come from
behind wins
hey guess what we found here inside the
fortress today we found a junior night
here is
owen schneider oh and i got to ask you
how fun is it to be part of the uh
the hockey program here in las vegas um
it's really exciting
and it's really fun now you came from
tampa bay so you were a lightning fan
you started playing hockey when you were
six you're 12 years old
how was how's the two programs here
because bill foley the owner always
wanted to build junior hockey here in
vegas
um i really like this like i like this
organization it's really exciting
and i like it like when we travel around
the us
now you're one of these elite teams to
the junior hockey team you're a center
right you play a center
tell us where you're going and what you
hope to achieve
we're going to go to quebec and we hope
that we win the tournament so
it's gonna be really fun what do you
like best about playing hockey
um i just like how the puck moves and
how you can make new friends and like
yeah now um tonight's a big game who's
your favorite
player on the golden knights team um i'm
gonna say mark stone
mark stone i like mark stone myself now
you're a tampa bay fan but you're now a
golden knights fan you like them both
i mean i like them both but i like
lightning a little bit more so a little
bit more because you grew up in tampa
bay but owen will be cheering
for the vegas golden knights tonight
we'll have much more from inside but
let's head now outside on the
toshiba plaza that is where we find john
treach hey john
hey there yeah puck drop is about an
hour and a half but the medieval maniac
migration has already started from
outside the fortress inside and yes they
will prepare to be the loudest
most obnoxiously deafening crowd in all
of the nhl and yes we take pride in that
is
this city has willed their team to a
comeback in this series it is 3-2 and
tell you what one more game and they
clinch it we found two fans here who are
going to their first playoffs
i got to ask you what this is your first
playoff game this year been it's been a
while
it was in the bubble in canada last year
how much do you not take it for granted
to be here oh man we're blessed to be
here
you know just you know thank god i mean
we get to be here enjoy it
i feel like we get to will the knights
to win you know get to erupt
i mean it's it's i feel like i've been
waiting for this moment for over a year
you know we went to a limited capacity
games
it's not the same i can't wait to feel
the energy vegas rocks
and jennifer may ask your your one
favorite thing about
the experience oh my gosh the noise
just everybody being so excited and like
you're
high-fiving people you don't even know
it's just it's amazing awesome well
thank you so much and
enjoy the game i tell you what jennifer
says her favorite thing is the noise i
can't say that's the same for the
avalanche fans
as yes the storm is coming game six in
about an hour and a half
reporting live outside the fortress john
treach eight sports now